Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday. Current me is actually on vacation, so this video is being made by five days ago me/ I hope it has been a calm, and peaceful five days.
Anyway it's Question Tuesday, the day that I answer real questions from real Nerdfighters, let's get right to it!
Q: Can we start with some good news?
A: Yeah there's a pretty good chance that no humans will contract polio this week,  which is something we've very rarely been able to say over the last several thousand years.
Advanced trials of an Ebola vaccine showed a 100% effectiveness rate
The U.S. economy has added jobs for 76 consecutive months
Plus Beyonce is pregnant
a new Zelda game is forthcoming
And humans, on average, are living longer, healthier and more prosperous lives than they were yesterday, or the day before that, or at any time in human history
Q: Diet Dr. Pepper or Cherry Diet Dr. Pepper?
While we're on the topic of good news
it is almost impossible to find Cherry Diet Dr. Pepper these days
which is great news, because Diet Dr. Pepper on its own is already perfect
Q:What's your opinion on bears?
Um, strongly in favor
In favor
Meh
Honestly, a little overrated
Opposed to
And in favor
Q: What's your opinion of glitter?
Sometimes Alice will put glitter on my face
And then like several days later even after many face washes
I'll discover there's still like one or two little pieces of glitter
And then I think 'you know, if glitter can do that billions of bacteria probably can too
Q: If you had a Tardis and could go anywhere in space and time, where would you go?
Well the past was worse, and I'm not feeling like totally confident in the future, so I would probably just go to present day New Zealand
because those people seem nice
Q: Why hasn't live news taken off on YouTube?
Let me answer your question with a question. Do we really need more live news?
What I need is like a pause button that, like, contextualizes the news for me and tells me what it means
Q: How are you coping with all the scary stuff in the world?
I don't know what you're talking about, I am a happy lobster in a pot of cool water
Does anyone else feel like the water is getting warmer?
Q: How excited are you for VidCon Europe in April?
Very excited. Not least because I haven't been back to Amsterdam
since The Fault in Our Stars move came out, and it will be fun to go to all of my old haunts.
Q: Any YA book recommendations?
Yes. The Hate U Give by Angie Thomas, which comes out later this month
And I truly believe it will be a classic.
Like, even if you don't love books you are going to love this book
I try not to inundate you with book recommendations but this is a very special book
Q: What's been your favorite part of 100 Days so far?
I think my favorite thing is how bad Chris and I are at high fives
Like we've been best friends for a decade without ever successfully completing a single high five
Q: Favorite song on the Hamilton mixtape?
Immigrants
Q: What's the secret of life?
I think maybe understanding that you deserve to love and be loved
Q: All-time favorite dystopia novel?
Yeah, I don't know. 1984 is definitely a great dystopia novel
but I feel like the one that we're living in has just amazing world building
Q: What's your favorite Pokemon?
Henry says the answer to this question is 'mega mewtwo ex'. Whatever that means
Q: What’s the most important song you’ve ever listened to?
John: That’s a great question because, of course, the most important songs you’ve ever listened are not necessarily the best ones.
There’ve been a few occasions in my life when a song crossed my path that I actually like needed
that gave form or expression to something deep down inside me that I couldn’t understand or look directly at.
The first one was probably the song I Think We're Alone Now by 1980's teen idol Tiffany
But also New Partner by the Palace Brothers, Love Love Love by the Mountain Goats
I put together a playlist of songs this question brought to my mind it's in the doobly doo below
Nerdfighters, I'd love to hear what songs or art in general you feel like are important to to you
And maybe we can discover cool stuff from each other
Alright, Hank. It's time for me to vacate.
I will see you on Friday.